TO GO UNTIL ELECTION DAY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN ABOUT TO SPEAK
AT A RALLY THERE FOR DEMOCRAT
TERRY McAULIFFE AND THE STATE'S
RACE FOR GOVERNOR.
IT IS THE MOST CLOSELY WATCHED
RACE IN THE COUNTRY.
A RACE WHERE McAULIFFE IS NECK
IN NECK WITH REPUBLICAN GLENN
YOUNGKIN.
THIS, DESPITE BIDEN BEATING
DONALD TRUMP BY TEN POINTS LAST
YEAR IN THE STATE.
WASN'T EVEN CLOSE THEN.
NOW, YOUNGKIN IS ALSO HOLDING A
RALLY RIGHT NOW.
OUTFRONT NOW, ACTRESS ALYSSA
MILANO.
SO, I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME AND I KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN
OBVIOUSLY VOCAL IN YOUR SUPPORT
ONLINE FOR McAULIFFE.
BOTH CANDIDATES ARE SAYING THIS
RACE IS CRUCIAL.
IT IS ABOUT THE DIRECTION OF THE
COUNTRY.
IN YOUR BOOK, YOU TALKED ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE LEARNED
CAMPAIGNS ARE NOT ABOUT
CANDIDATES, OBVIOUSLY, BUT ABOUT
VOTERS WHICH IS REALLY
INTERESTING OBSERVATION.
YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT AND A
PROGRESSIVE.
WHAT -- WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
FACT THAT THIS RACE IS AS CLOSE
AS IT IS?
WHAT MESSAGE DOES THAT SEND
ABOUT VOTERS?
>> WELL ACTUALLY, POLLS SHOW
THAT THE ELECTION IS TIED WHICH
IS INCREDIBLE.
UM, YOU KNOW, McAULIFFE IS A
FORMER GOVERNOR.
HE'S GOT THE EXPERIENCE.
HE IS A DNC HEAD.
UM, AND YOUNGKIN WHO, IN MY
OPINION, IS VERY TRUMPY BUT
TRYING TO HIDE THAT ASPECT OF
WHO HE IS.
SO I FEEL LIKE VIRGINIA IS
REALLY AT A CROSSROADS.
AND, YOU KNOW, I GET IT.
I KNOW THAT MANY PEOPLE ARE
TIRED AND I FEEL LIKE POLITICS
IS TIRING.
BUT AS PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID THE
OTHER DAY IN VIRGINIA, WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO BE TIRED.
WE HAVE TO GET OUT THERE AND
VOTE.
UM, ALSO, I HAVE A SOFT SPOT IN
MY HEART BECAUSE VIRGINIA WAS
THE 38th STATE TO RATIFY THE
EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT.
AND LAST THURSDAY, I TESTIFIED
IN FRONT OF CONGRESS TO LIFT THE
POISON PILL DEADLINE PLACED ON
THE EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT.
SO, YEAH, PLEASE, VIRGINIA, GET
OUT THERE AND VOTE.
>> SO YOU TALK THABT TESTIMONY.
AND YOU DID TESTIFY BEFORE
CONGRESS.
YOU WANT THEM TO PASS OBVIOUSLY
THE LEGISLATION TO END GENDER
DISCRIMINATION.
THIS IS YOU HERE LAST WEEK AND
YOU WERE ARRESTED DURING A
PROTEST OUTSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE
OVER THE PUSH TO PROTECT VOTING
RIGHTS AND YOU WRITE ABOUT THIS
IN YOUR BOOK AND YOUR DECISION
TO CARE SO DEEPLY ABOUT THESE
THING, WHY YOU DO THIS.
AND THINGS THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAS PROMISED TO STAND UP FOR.
HERE IT IS.
>> WE HAVE TO PROTECT THAT
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT, THE RIGHT TO
VOTE, THE SACRED RIGHT TO VOTE.
>> I TOLD MY GIRLS AND MY -- MY
DAUGHTERS AND MY GRANDDAUGHTERS
NOT A SINGLE THING, NOT A SINGLE
THING, THAT A MAN CAN DO THAT A
WOMAN CAN'T DO EQUALLY AS WELL.
NOTHING.
AND I WILL NOT BE SATISFIED
UNTIL THAT'S RECOGNIZED.
>> SO, YOU WRITE ABOUT IT AND
YOU HAVE ALSO ACTED ON IT,
RIGHT?
YOU HAVE TESTIFIED.
YOU HAVE BEEN ARRESTED IN --
IN -- FOR THIS CAUSE.
DO YOU BELIEVE PRESIDENT BIDEN
IS DOING ENOUGH TO MAKE THESE
REALITIES TO ACTUALLY GET THIS
LEGISLATION PASSED?
OR COULD HE BE DOING MORE?
>> SO JUST TO CLARIFY, I WAS
ARRESTED ACTUALLY BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, IN MY OPINION, WE ELECTED
A -- A DEMOCRATIC GOVERNMENT,
SPECIFICALLY -- SPECIFICALLY --
SORRY -- TO GET HIS AGENDA DONE.
A PROGRESSIVE AGENDA DONE.
AND IN MY LIFETIME, THIS AGENDA
IS THE MOST PROGRESSIVE AGENDA
AND IT'S WHAT PEOPLE WANT.
SO NOW, WE NEED OUR GOVERNMENT
TO DELIVER.
AND SO, I WAS ARRESTED.
YOU KNOW, I TOOK A FIGHT RIGHT
UP TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE FREEDOM TO VOTE ACT IS
SOMETHING THAT MEANS A LOT TO
THIS COUNTRY.
THE FREEDOM TO VOTE IS THE
BEDROCK OF OUR NATION.
STATES HAVE INTRODUCED 425 BILLS
MAKING IT HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO
VOTE.
13 REPUBLICAN-LED STATES HAVE
PASSED 33 LAWS AIMED AT MAKING
IT MORE DIFFICULT TO VOTE.
AND I WENT TO THE WHITE HOUSE
WITH PEOPLE FOR THE AMERICAN
WAY, AND WE WANT BIDEN -- WE'RE
DEMANDING OF BIDEN -- TO USE ALL
OF HIS POWER AND INFLUENCE TO --
TO GET PASSED THE FREEDOM TO
VOTE ACT, THE JOHN LEWIS VOTING
RIGHTS ADVANCEMENT ACT, AND D.C.
STATEHOOD AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
EVEN IF THAT MEANS GETTING RID
OF THE FILIBUSTER.
>> AND OF COURSE, OBVIOUSLY, THE
PRESIDENT IS -- MAYBE, STARTED
TO MOVE A LITTLE BIT ON THAT.
BUT -- BUT HAS NOT AS OF YET.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT ONE
OTHER THING, ALYSSA, BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HEARD RACHEL
THE CINEMATOGRAPHER WHO WAS ON
BEFORE YOU CAME ON.
BUT SHE WAS DUST -- JUST HER
LOSS AND OUTRAGE AT WHAT
HAPPENED.
TALKING ABOUT HALYNA HUTCHINS
WHO WAS KILLED OBVIOUSLY WHEN
ALEC BALDWIN DISCHARGED THAT
PROP FIREARM.
UM, YOU KNOW, WHEN WE WERE
HAVING YOU ON TONIGHT, WAS
THINKING ABOUT, YOU KNOW, YOUR
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS.
FOUND A VIDEO OF YOU IN 2008
HOLDING A GUN IN SCENES, RIGHT?
YOU HAVE BEEN AROUND GUNS ON
SETS.
YOU HAVE DEALT WITH THIS.
UM, AND RACHEL MORRISON, WHO I
JUST MENTIONED THE
OSCAR-NOMINATED CINEMATOGRAPHER.
SHE JUST TOLD ME THERE IS NO
NEED TO HAVE REAL GUNS ON SET
ANYMORE.
DO YOU AGREE?
>> I AGREE.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO REFOCUS THIS
CONVERSATION BECAUSE IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT MY INDUSTRY.
WE NEED COMMON SENSE CHANGES TO
THE WAY WE INTERACT WITH GUNS
ACROSS THE ENTIRE NATION.
UM, ALSO, THERE'S ALMOST 1,700
ACCIDENTAL SHOOTING DEATHS SO
FAR THIS YEAR.
UM, THAT'S ON PACE TO HAVE
NEARLY 2,000 BY THE END OF THE
YEAR.
UM, AND SO, YOU KNOW, MANDATING
SAFE STORAGE, TRIGGER LOCKS, AND
INVESTING IN A BIOMETRIC SYSTEM
FOR WEAPONS COULD REALLY REDUCE
ALL OF THESE ACCIDENTAL
SHOOTINGS.
AND -- AND IT'S SO SAD TO ME
THAT THINGS ALWAYS HAVE TO
HAPPEN IN INDUSTRY WHERE PEOPLE
ARE SORT OF FAMOUS TO GET THE
COUNTRY TO PAY ATTENTION.
BUT I WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT
CHILDREN ARE SHOT IN MASS
SHOOTINGS EVERY SINGLE YEAR AND
IT SHOULDN'T BE EASIER TO FIRE
YOUR GUN THAN IT IS TO UNLOCK
YOUR iPHONE.
>> WELL SAID.
ALL RIGHT.
TH